ah November a time of food family and
friends and yes I'm talking about the
wondrous day of gluttony known as
Thanksgiving oh yeah and then there's
that day after Thanksgiving thing the
day that people stand in the cold rain
sleet and snow so they can be the first
to trample clon scamper the way through
the store at 5:00 a.m. and sacrifice
their dignity just save a buck on little
Timmy's ps3 yeah I'm gonna go ahead and
say little Timmy's way too spoiled and
why 5:00 a.m. they kind of just as
easily made it regular store hours so
people wouldn't cut out of Thanksgiving
early to stand in a line all night and
freeze their nuts off and fYI if you
duck at a Thanksgiving early to go stand
in a line your priorities officially
[ __ ] blow but why stand in a line I
mean some companies like Best Buy have
the items that they're gonna sell on
Black Friday on sale on their website
like this second so just buy it online I
mean this stuff is on sale for damn near
the same price it's gonna be on Black
Friday
maybe a negligible amount more oh no
that $2,400 TVs only knocked down to
seventeen hundred dollars online as
opposed to sixteen hundred dollars if
you wait in line with a Friday morning
circus degenerates I'm not saying there
aren't savings to be had on Black Friday
I'm just saying they should call it what
it really is but what my dignity is
really worth sale because there is no
way that being a part of this leaves you
with any dignity whatsoever because the
fact is in order to walk out of the
store on Black Friday with what you came
for you have to be just as cutthroat as
everyone else there you have to become
this because when swimming with the
sharks you cannot be a guppy yeah that's
a guppy and I'm going to go ahead and
lift the retail veil apparently most
people have this delusion that during
these holiday sales retail stores have
in the back Santa's magic bag in which
upon request from any given customer the
employee needs only to make a wish reach
his hand into the bag and he will pull
out set item that the customer requests
an endless supply of sale items for
everybody yeah they don't there is in
fact a strong possibility that after all
that waiting you might just walk out of
that store with a broken heart in fact
it's a probability because if you're
waiting there for that hot item then
everyone's probably there for the same
thing
and if they only have five in stock yeah
that guy
number six yeah he's not getting one so
don't get pissed and chew out some
part-time employee with less than no
power if you end up being number six do
not be this guy you won't tell me but
you're staying on failure you don't even
have it well I'm sorry sir we only had
somebody in stock and unfortunately we
just sold out you only got so many so
money ain't enough idiot
I've been waiting in line all night you
don't tell me I can't get well I'm sorry
but no like I said we only sorry doesn't
get it to me that does it why aren't you
or more I don't do that sir I just went
there's false advertisement you run
their bait and switch air boy no you
know what just save it just save it no
you just lost yourself cooking
yeah that'll probably happen 700 times
over that day to that kid who makes 6
bucks an hour because if you don't get
your needful thing on Friday you can
just get it the next time it's on sale
honestly holiday sales are like
playmates when one dries up three more
that are just like it pop up to take its
place it will not be the last time that
thing goes on sale before Christmas now
I'm not saying you won't save a few more
bucks if you do get that item by
becoming part of a circuit dip shits on
Friday I'm just saying it's not worth it
because electing not to become this
shows a couple of little things like
dignity and self-worth and that's pretty
much priceless so stay home and enjoy a
day of sleeping in after justifiably
pigging out on Thanksgiving leave Black
Friday to Kimbo Slice and the people
whose New Year's resolution is going to
be nothing more than to finally make
that submission video to Springer
they've been talking about all these
years and of course subscribe to my
channel by going to my channel by
clicking the link on the sidebar and
hitting subscribe so you can enjoy more
educational videos like this one time
too but whatever you do definitely enjoy
your turkey day